i wish i had if i'd had a snake i'd pet
one man i got one you want one did you
guys really bring how do you bring one
yeah you want to get it
i was just saying that
i think you should i think you should if
you'd be here with me man i'm here i'm
here man i'm right here all right let's
get one man let's see what's what's
going on and
and where's this snake from brother all
right
hang on a second
oh jesus christ
he shouldn't have done it
so theo i'm gonna start small okay whoa
whoa dog what you doing man come on man
this is small i'm gonna start small i've
got one other snake you gotta check out
but check this out this is called a pie
ball ball python look it's got a smiley
face on it okay and it's got an upside
down smiley face okay come on mate now
is these glasses is this is this going
to scare him nope not at all this is
drama oh come on man that dude's moving
around bubby
just hold your hands out like this
you're gonna be good he's gonna know i'm
scared because i know i'm scared right
now he's not gonna care he doesn't
matter well what about me you can be
scared but you're not going to be afraid
because you're going to feel it you're
going to be like holy cow that's way
cooler than i expected he can't bite
through this can he he can't invite you
ever all right i promise you okay so
what's going to happen then this is can
i just put them on the ground can i put
them on the table or should i put them
in the air
what if i have these braces is that
going to scare him
i don't want him scared dude
let me just touch him first
doesn't feel like it's not slimy okay
cool so
you ready you'll be fine and then just
do this real quick and then i got one
other thing i'll show you see that's not
bad right the thought of holding a snake
is way worse than actually holding steak
he's just chilling okay okay good all
right let me show you one more jesus dog
damn bro
i think i just had a uh
egg birth in my heart
i feel like i just had a pair of what
y'all
damn boy now this one's gonna go around
your neck
damn bro come on bro
this one's gonna go around your neck all
right
this is what super sweet it's the only
way you can hold on dude i can't even
hear you right now
you have to give me at least 10 seconds
man to chime in man all right
damn bro all right you're gonna be fine
okay now what is that snake doing
where's that snake from man this snake
is a burmese python it's albino burmese
python and it's not going to do anything
it's super tame super i mean this is i
mean it seems like it wants to do
something it's around like five-year-old
kids all day long god dude
you ready
yeah now what are you going to do you're
going to put it on me and then what do i
do to sit here sit here and i'll take
them off when you tell me okay all right
super simple well it just hold on dog
it just was breathing it's just
breathing why can't he [ __ ] just
breathe real quietly more quietly dude
it's breathing like a dam like it's damn
we got a v6 in its neck it's going to be
fine
i got you all right okay let's wait till
it's looking away all right i'm going to
take it like this so it's looking away
you tell me when you're ready okay and
it's not going to go up my sleeves or
anything is it should i pin my sleeves
closed nope you're good
you're good i got you all right just
like this yep
like this
and if you put this hand out like that
you can control its head and you're set
see
you did it you proud yeah you won can
you take him i got you thank you brother
you got it jesus christ bro
yeah that was awesome right fears dude
that's what i feel scared good man you
did good you should be proud of yourself
man
that's good stuff isn't it
yeah can i try one more time with you
yes of course okay i just want to feel
out here i want to feel the fear again i
told you
i told you this is how it happens all
right
am i good you're good
he's just kind of cruising around do i
hold him or anything you're good all
right
and how do i seem okay you're good i
mean you seem a little stiff that's fine
he seems fine he's happy
you can move you can breathe you can do
all that normal stuff that people do all
right
ladies and gentlemen we're grateful
we are grateful you're here tonight
thank you
this episode brought to you by liquid
death
or just regular death
okay what is he looking at still looking
at the plant okay good
yeah man he seems wow i think it's just
that
he doesn't seem like a bad guy
no he's a good dad trust me i only
brought good ones okay thank you
okay i think i'm okay for today that's
good though
goodbye buddy
there you go wow
you did good brother i'm proud of you
you're powerful
it's like you won it's like you won
away i feel a little bit more
yeah like i want to like just like i did
something you know like i leaned into
the discomfort oh geez no worries
it means it's his lunch time i'm sure
yeah that's it
just in time just in time i took them
back so close yeah it's so close
wow man that's amazing dude yeah it's
cool right i mean when you do it it's
kind of it's mesmerizing right oh yeah
that's what i told you is that people
that just like you you know afraid then
you do it and you're like let me do that
again man let me do that again and then
next thing you know you're like really
into it i'm telling you you know if you
were close to me you'd be at my place
every day you'd be like holy crap this
thing is awesome you know
when we come up man i owe you a vlog
i'll come in there when we come up and
we'll do something fun man you have to
show me around a little bit i'll try to
be more a little a little bit more brave
you're you were brave man you did great
dude i feel good it definitely makes me
feel something it makes me feel like i
did something i didn't want to do a
little bit you know
yeah i feel a little bit more
like uh maybe i don't know if it's maybe
a little bit more confidence i think
you're i think you could see it actually
i could see it in your face you went
from like terrified in the beginning to
almost like wow this is all right i got
this man i got this that's pretty
awesome you should be proud of yourself
i'm proud of you thank you
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one